[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so adorable they're right there Travis
got the latest posts of his
nine-month-old daughter stormy her
reaction to watching her dad perform at
Madison Square Garden is so priceless
Travis stormy and Kylie have formed
quite the loving family yes yes yes
Kylie posted this to Instagram of the
family on Thanksgiving with the caption
thankful you love it then around the
same time Travis posted his video
Kylie posted this photo with the caption
then look the look you gave when your
hubby is performing at Madison Square
Garden this serves some speculation that
perhaps they have been secretly married
hmm
but a source recently told ET that is
just a term of endearment but that they
are quote madly in love people call
their none man or women wifey or hubby
yeah yeah and to tell you the truth
though when Kylie came out and we got
that huge like just like I don't know
what to call that she was pregnant the
video everything I was super I was
celebrating Kylie I was happy for her
you know and I think that people because
they she has Kardashian adjacent they
immediately had these really quick
judgment they rush to judgment knee-jerk
reaction is oh she's this she's that
yeah but she just brought life into this
world and from that picture they're
happy and that's a good thing a happy
family is a good thing I agree so do you
think they will get married soon i knows
but if they do good for them yeah i
don't think they're in any rush one
thing about kylie i will say is that it
pays off to be the baby sister cuz you
learn from all your other sisters your
older sisters and mistakes and i think i
mean she's doing it right i might
opinion and then this this woman's on
the front of forbes okay so she's
wedding and we don't know her
we don't know their relationship we only
know what they what they show us but
everything they do show us see shows
that they are on the up and up so well
it definitely seems like stormy has
allowed their relationship to grow up
grow closer you know yes so privately
kylie so it's super cute i love it
[Music]
[Applause]